Oh
so there's an amazing documentary called
flight from death in which an expert
introduces the concept of terror
management theory now terror management
theory was coined by Ernest Becker to
describe the ways in which the human
being responds to the unbearable
awareness of the mortal coil like the
fact that we know that we are born with
a death sentence and use our life with
an agitation that we have to respond to
in some kind of either creative or
destructive capacity and that is known
as terror management theory how we
manage the terror of creation and
mortality right and there's a line in
the film that's really poignant one of
the guys says the explicit awareness
that you're a breathing piece of
defecating meat destined to die and
ultimately no more significant than a
lizard or a potato is not especially of
lifting right and you know it really
sets up the premise it's like what do we
do right you know we're a creature that
can ponder the infinite that can
contemplate infinity that can ponder the
origins of the 10 trillion atoms that
make us make us a sentient mind that
were cooked in the furnaces of stars
billions of years ago ultimately and at
the same time you know look in the
mirror every day and witness our own
decay over time the human situation is
absurd and I don't know you know there's
something there's something romantic in
the ways in which we respond to this
angst in our in our poems and
and in our artistry but nonetheless
there's a sadness inherence to just our
humaneness there's a sadness to that
awareness
you